Welcome to our extra challenged problems. This is
the first in will be a set of problems designed to
test, refresh, and reinforce the various skills we’ve
learned in the class. I recommend that if you’re still
working through the class then you finish that first
and then come back to this challenged problems
later. Before we get to the first problem, I want to
tell a quick story.
I used to live in Chicago and I wanted to bike for
my apartment in Lakeview down to work in the
Loop, so I did what anybody would do and I looked
for directions online and the suggested route took
me along the Lake Shore bike path and basically
cut across to work. This seems like a great route,
it’s along the bike path, along the lake, which is a
very pretty ride, unfortunately it’s also a very
popular place for people to walk, for people to run,
and for people to take the dogs for a walk and it’s
actually a very hard place to bike.
The suggested route along the Lake Shore might
have been based on some factors such as
distance or how hilly the route was and whether
you want a bike path or a bike lane and there is
probably some other ones but they don’t take dogs
into account. One possible solution is to find two
paths and then let the user choose between the
two options. If you’re curious, I ended up taking a
route down Clark Street and Wells Street to work.
Now with that idea, in this assignment, we want
you to take a graph and a starting node and
calculate the top two paths every node – every
other node in that graph. In addition to passing the
greater you should try to write your algorithm as
efficiently as possible. There is a link to the form
where you can discuss your approach and your
calculated run time. If you post code, please
explain what you are doing at each step and why?